backend engineering is a very wide scope
and when I say backend engineering it is
much more than building a set of crud
apis the way I think backend engineering
is about building reliable scalable fall
tolerant and maintainable code bases and
efficient
systems and if one were to start today
to learn back in development there are a
lot of resources and
at least 1,00
resources but how do you decide what to
learn how do you prioritize how do you
see the big picture when and how all
these different concepts come together
and this is the reason it takes people
years to get their head around a lot of
these Concepts and principles because
people primarily start with a limited
scope of training uh whether it is from
a college or a boot camp or a simple cop
course and they eventually build onp top
of that with trial and error and with
help of other developers over time now I
am a backend engineer and I have faced
this struggle initially when I started
out I had to constantly search for
resources learn from other developers I
have read a lot of books on backend
development I have studied hundreds of
open- source code bases to see how
people in the industry are building
stuff and it was a very timec consuming
procedure and the second problem is
people start with backend development
from a particular language or Frameworks
point of view it could be Express or
spring boot or Ruby on Rails and the
problem with that is you look at the
problems that you solve with the lens of
your particular language and ecosystem
and there are blind spots in that let's
imagine you have to switch to a
different language let's say you were
working with rubyan rails for years and
one day your company decided to migrate
to golang for performance reasons in
that situation how much of your
knowledge can you transfer if you don't
understand the underlying systems so
here I have decided to put together a
comprehensive list of videos which are
based on foundational concepts of a
backend system and these are from
various books that I've read over the
years the open source code base we'll
start with a very high level
understanding of how backend systems
work behind the scenes we'll look at how
request from browser flows through
different hops the network firewalls
over the internet and how it is routed
to our backend server that is situated
in a remote AWS server and how it
responds to that request and we'll look
at what the response looks like and that
should give us a pretty vivid idea of
how systems communicate how a client
communicates with a server and how the
server responds from there we'll move to
understanding HTTP protocol what is the
role it plays and how the communication
is established through HTTP and how HTTP
raw messages look like and what are the
HTTP headers what are the role of the
headers the different types of headers
like request headers or representational
headers General headers and security
headers and we'll look at different
types of HTTP methods like get method
post put delete and when to use them and
what are the semantics and what are the
principles behind them we'll look at
what is the cost flow and how does it
work we'll look at how simple request
defers from a pre-flight request and how
a pre-flight request FL looks like from
our browser to the server and back to
our browser we'll look at HTTP responses
the structure of it and different status
codes that server returns and when to
return which type of code and what are
the most commonly used HTTP status codes
then we'll look at HTTP caching what are
the different types of caching
techniques using HTTP we have eags we
have uh max age headers then we'll look
at the differences between http 1. 1 and
HTTP 2.0 and HTTP 3.0 and what are the
differences between them we will look at
how content negotiation looks like
between client and server using
different headers we'll see how
persistent connections work in HTTP
we'll look at HTTP compression different
types of compression techniques like
gzip and deflate and BR and which is the
commonly used technique we'll see the
security aspect of it the SSL TLS and
htps then we'll move on to routing how
routing Maps URLs to server side logic
and what is the connection between
routing and HTTP methods different
components of routes like path
parameters and query parameters
different types of routes static routes
Dynamic routes nested routes
hierarchical routes catchall Wild Card
routes and regular expression based
routes how to do API versioning using
HTTP different types of versioning
techniques we'll see what is the best
way to deprecate it outout and what are
the best practices in the industry we
look at the benefits of Route grouping
and how it helps with versioning
permissions and shared middleware we'll
see how to secure routes how to optimize
route matching performance then we'll
move on to serialization and der
serialization this basically means how
before sending it over to the network
our server translates the data into a
particular format and after receiving
the data from uh let's say client over
the internet and how and how it
translates the data received from the
client over the internet to its own
native format that is called DC
realization and we will see what is the
need of it and how it helps with the
interoperability standard the different
formats that are used in serialization
der serialization we have text based
formats which is Json or XML we have
binary formats which is prot off and
what are the performance differences
between these two and when to use which
one we'll look at how different
programming languages Implement
serialization and der serialization we
will explore a popular text based format
for serialization and der serialization
which is Json the structure of Json the
different data types like strings
numbers booleans arrays and objects how
realization of nested objects and
collections are handled in Json how DC
serializing into data structures the
native data structures works like in
let's say python dictionary or goang
structs or JavaScript object what are
the common errors while dealing with
Json like handling missing or extra
Fields dealing with null values or date
serialization issues and time zone
issues and how to implement custom
serialization while before sending or
serializing data into Json we'll look at
error handling and serialization der
serialization for example invalid data
data conversion errors unknown Fields
look at the security concerns if it like
injection attacks why to do validation
before DC realization and validating
Json schemas before processing data
using Json schema validation we'll see
the performance aspect of it like
reducing the serialized data through
compression and eliminating unnecessary
Fields like serialization performance
between text based and binary formats
like Json versus protuff the tradeoffs
between readability and performance
because in text based format you can
easily check the payload and see that
does not work the same in binary formats
but binary formats are faster so when
you you use a binary format and when you
use a text Bas format that is a valid
trade-off then we'll move to
authentication and authorization why do
we use it different types of
authentication like State full State L
we have basic authentication better
token authentications we'll look at
sessions jws cookies we'll Deep dive on
oo protocol and open ID connect we'll
see how API keys work how multiactor
authentications work what is salting
hashing and different cryptographic
techniques used in authorization we'll
explore aack rback reback we'll look at
what are the best practices in security
like securing cookies avoiding csrf xss
mitm like audit logging which basically
means recording authentication
authorization events for Audits and
monitoring failed login attempts
privilege escalation and access to
sensitive resources we'll look at a
skating authenticated related error
messages preventing information leakage
to attackers through detailed error
messages like handling edge cases for
example consistency in responses across
different failure modes like rate
limiting and account lockout we'll see
how to avoid timing attacks for example
attackers can exploit time differences
in error responses to infer valid
credentials for example an error for a
wrong password might take longer than an
error for a valid username because to
check for a password you have to do some
kind of hashing uh or uh some use some
kind of cryptographic technique which
takes a little bit of time so people can
General the tiny bit of timing
difference between them and guess
passwords even though that's very
difficult but we don't want to keep any
security Halls then the next topic we'll
explore is validation and transformation
the different types of validation like
syntactic validation for example
checking whether resting is a email or
not whether it is a valid phone number
or not or whether it is a valid date
format or not there is semantic valid
for example a date uh a date of birth
cannot be in the future or the age of a
person should be between one and 120
these are called semantic validations
then we have type validation for example
checking the input values match expected
types whether it is a string or not
whether it is an integer or not whether
it is an array or not whether it is an
object or not these types of checks are
called type validation we'll see what
are the best practices for validation
what is the difference between client
side validation and what is the of
server side validation the importance of
server side validation even if client
side validation is already implemented
because client side validation improves
user experience by providing instant
feedback but server side validation is
the true security implementation because
that is the gateway to your business
logic we'll look at the importance of
failing fast by reducing unnecessary
processing by returning early and we'll
look at uh why to keep consistency
between front end validation and backend
validation then there is Transformations
for example type casting converting
string to number or number to string
because uh in query parameters or path
parameters whatever we receive is a
string but let's say we are expecting an
ID field which is a number so before we
send it to our handlers we have to
convert that string into a number so
that step is called a transformation
which we have to take care of in our
validation Pipeline and different date
formats for example the front end might
send a different format or we might be
expecting a time stamp so that also has
to taken care of in the validation
pipeline then there is normalization for
example converting an email to lower
case or trimming white space from a
string or adding country code to a phone
number these are called normalizations
then there is sanitization for security
issues for example we have to sanitize a
string that is submitted by the user to
prevent attacks like SQL injection then
there is complex validation Logic for
example relationships let's say User
submitted a form and it has two Fields
one is password and another is confirm
password so we have to check whether the
two strings are the same or not so that
is a relationship based validation then
there is conditional validation so let's
say in the form there are two Fields one
is partner name and the second is
married which is a Boolean true or false
so a partner field might only be
required if the married is true so that
is a conditional validation so these
kinds of checks we have to do then there
is chain validation like converting a
string to lower case then roving special
characters and then checking its length
then we'll look at error handling in
validation like sending meaningful error
messages to front end so that the user
can fix them and aggregating all
validation errors in one response for
client side display or Aus skating error
messages so instead of saying invalid
password we'll have to say invalid
credentials to prevent different types
of attacks then we will see how to
gracefully handle failed Transformations
for example an invalid Json and a failed
date conversion and how to let the user
know in a meaningful message then we'll
look at the performance trade-offs of
validation and how to optimize it by
returning early avoiding redundant
validations then our next topic is going
to be middleware we'll look at what is a
middleware and when to use them what are
the common use cases of middlewares the
role of a middleware in a request cycle
for example a pre-quest middleware or a
post response middleware the flow of
middlewares for example techniques like
chaining a middleware is executed in a
sequence passing control to the next
middleware until request reaches its
final Handler how to order middleware is
appropriate for example we have to go in
this order we have to log the request we
have to check whether the user is
authenticated or not we have to do
validation and we have to do route
handling and then we have to do error
handling so this order matters in
middleware flow we'll see how the next
function Works in middleware and exiting
middleware early how middleware can SE
circuit the request pipeline by handling
404 errors we'll look at some of the
common middlewares like security
middlewares which add security headers
like X content type or strict Transport
Security or content security policy or
middlewares which add appropriate course
headers to every single request or
response and middleware to avoid csrf
attack middleware to rate limit then we
have authentication middleware to reuse
the route protecting logic across our
apps then we have logging and monitoring
middlewares for request logging or
structur logging for observability or
easier debugging in production then we
have error handling middlewares which
catches and form mats application Level
errors for consistent API responses then
we have compression or performance
related middlewares which basically
compresses response bodies to reduce the
size of data sent over the networks then
we have data passing middleware passing
incoming request bodies like Json URL
encoded forms and file uploads handles
multiplatform data for the file uploads
then we'll look at the performance and
scalability aspect of middleware like
what are the best practices to keep
middlewares lightweight and efficient
ensuring middleware is applied in the
correct order or how how middleware
order can affect the performance and
security of the application the next
topic is going to be request context
request context basically means the
metadata that is often passed through
application middlewares controllers and
services it is kind of a request coped
State right the state is only valid for
that request so here we'll explore the
life cycle of a request maintaining
State for the duration of a request
sharing data across different layers of
the application without coupling how
context provides a temporary request
scoped State we look at what are the
different components of a request
context the request metadata for example
the HTTP method the URL headers the
query parameters and the body and there
is the session and user information for
example in the authentication middleware
we fetch the user information and then
we add it to the request context so for
that request scope the users information
is injected into the context then we
have tracking and loging information
like unique request IDs or Trace IDs
then we have request specific data like
custom data in injected during the
request life cycle like caching data
permission checks we'll look at what are
the use cases for example authentication
rate limiting tracing logging we'll
explore the connection between
middlewares and request contexts we'll
see what are the different types of
timeouts the request timeouts custom
timeouts cancellation signals we'll see
what are the best practices like keeping
it lightweight to prevent memory
overhead ensuring context data is
cleaned up after request life cycle to
prevent memory leaks avoiding tightly
coupling components through context or
over relying on it for passing data then
we'll move to handlers and controllers
the MVC pattern and what handlers and
controllers and services the
responsibilities of all of them and
reducing code with middleware then we
have centralized error handling in
handlers and consistent success and
error message formats and how to
implement them in controllers then we'll
look at the different types of crud
operations like how cud operations map
HTTP methods and what are the common
apis associated with each method for
example post method is usually used for
creation and submissions and the status
code is usually 2011 created or a400 if
it's a bad request and get requests are
usually associated with fetching a list
of resources or fetching a single
resource and we have put and Patch to
update resources and delete to delete
resources we look at how to implement
pagination and how to implement a search
API how to do sorting and how to do
filtering and we'll see what are the
best practices for example strict
validation consistent response
formatting limiting payload redacting
sensitive Fields error handling
authentication and authorization then
we'll explore what is the restful
architecture and what are the best
practices for implementing rest apis the
principle of Designing apis around
resources and sticking to sttp semantics
and best practices for filtering and
pagination uh what are the different
types of versioning like URI versioning
header versioning query string media
type we'll see how to design apis with
open API spec in mind you'll see content
negotiation capturing exceptions and
providing meaningful messages supporting
client side caching e taxs and
optimizing large requests and responses
after that we'll move on to a very
important topic which are databases in
databases we'll look at relational and
non-relational what are the differences
and to when to use which we look at some
of the theoretical Concepts like acid
and cap theorem we'll take a look at
basic quering and joints and database
design best practices like schema design
indexing we look at different
optimization methods like query
optimization caching connection pooling
then we have data Integrity like
constraints and validations transactions
and concurrency we'll see how ORS work
whether to use an orm what are the
tradeoffs and we'll look at what are
database migrations that we'll move on
to business logic layer which is also
called BL what is the role of it what
are the different layers of a request
cycle for example we have validation
layer we have routing we have
middlewares and we have handl and
controls which all of them fall under
presentation layer because they they
deal with users data whether it is
accepting users data or sending a user
data so those are part of a presentation
layer after that we have business logic
layer which is the middle one which
deals with our Core Business logic and
after that we have the data access layer
which deals with databases perform
squaring or inserts or deletions and
business logic layer uses the data
access layer behind the scenes we'll
look at different design principles like
separation of concerns single
responsibility open close dependency
inversion what are the components of a
business logic layer for example we have
Services we have domain models which
represent core entities like a user or
an order then we have business tools
then we have business validation logic
we'll look at service layer design best
practices we'll look at how to handle
errors properly and how to propagate
those errors from our service layer to
our presentation layer after that we
have caching we'll discuss what is the
need of caching and how it differs from
database persistence what are the
different types of caching we have
memory caching browser caching database
caching and what is the need of client
side caching and server side caching the
different caching strategies for example
cash aside right through right behind or
right back read through the different
cash eviction strategies for example lru
lfu TTL and fifo need for cash
invalidation like manual Cash
invalidation Time To Live invalidation
or event bash invalidation the different
levels of caching level one which is in
memory level two which is Network
distributed and there is is the
hierarchical caching which combines
level one and level two caching
strategies where frequently used data is
stored in a fast small cach which is the
level one cache and the less frequently
used data is stored in a slower or large
cach which is the level two cache we'll
see how caching for web apps looks like
that is caching static assets or caching
API responses using headers we'll see
how to cach with databases for example
query caching like storing the results
of heavy joints in redis and look at
Cash hit and cash Miss ratio and how to
optimize them after that we'll move on
to transactional emails what are the use
of them what are the common use cases
the anatomy of a transactional email the
subject the preheader the body header
main content CTA footer and how to
personalize with different Dynamic
parameters then we have task queuing and
scheduling what are the common use cases
for example queuing might be used for
sending emails or processing image files
and third party API integration like
Payment Processing or web hooks or
offloading heavy computation like badge
processing for example a user clicks a
button to clear all my data so to clear
all the users data we have to call we
have to execute different queries for
different tables to clear all the users
data and that might take some time so
instead of blocking the request we
return the response instantly and we
trigger a background job by pushing into
the task Cube we'll look at scheduling
what are the use cases for example for
example running database backups
recurring notifications and reminders
data synchronization or maintenance
related issues for example clearing logs
or caches the different components of a
task Q There is the producer Q consumer
broker backend the flow of a task
dependency for example it might be chain
dependency or it might have parent child
relationship we look at task groups
executing multiple task concurrently and
waiting for all of them to complete at
the same time we look at how to handle
errors and Implement retries in task use
we'll look at task prioritization and
and rate limiting for example giving
importance to task like Payment
Processing before you process task like
sending notifications after that we'll
move on to elastic search why do we use
elastic search and how does it work
behind the scenes the different
techniques that are used for example
inverted index term frequency and
inverse document frequency segments and
shards what are the use cases of elastic
search for example providing a type
ahead experience or log analytics or
social media search for example full
text search for user profiles posts
comments we'll see how to create and
manage indexes we'll see how to search
and query different types of searching
basic searching full text search
relevance scoring we'll see how to
optimize search performance by tweaking
text versus keyword Fields understanding
analyzers and boosting and pagination
we'll take a look at some of the
advanced search patterns for example
filtering aggregation fuzzy search then
we'll see how kibana works and how to
use elastic search in a user friendly
way and different best practices for
example defining field mappings
explicitly optimizing the number number
of shards indexing data in batches and
avoiding wild cards then we have error
handling the different types of errors
in our apps could be syntax errors
runtime errors logical errors and
different error handling strategies for
example fail safe or fail fast graceful
degradation or prevention of Errors
different practices for error handling
for example catching early not
swallowing errors custom error types
failing gracefully logging errors and
using stack traces we'll look at how
Global error handlers work we'll see how
to appropriate handle user facing errors
like providing friendly error messages
and providing actionable feedbacks we'll
see the importance of monitoring and
logging in error handling and different
tools like Sentry or elk stack and
different error alerts like email based
alerts and slack based alerts after that
we have config management what is
exactly config management and how does
it help with flexibility and decouples
environment specific settings from
application logic and what are the use
cases for example example different
environments using config management
safely managing sensitive data such as
API Keys database passwords and private
certificates dynamically enabling and
disabling features without changing
codebase what are the best practices of
config management different types of
configs for example static configs like
DB credentials and API end points
Dynamic configs like feature Flags rate
limits and sensitive configs like
credentials tokens secrets and different
sources of configs for example it could
be EnV file or Json or yaml and what are
the differences between using
environment variables versus command
line Flags versus static files after
that we have logging monitoring and
observability a very important topic
we'll see what are the differences
between logging tracing monitoring and
observability the different types of
logging like system logging application
access security logs the different
levels of logs like debug info one error
fatal and we'll see the difference
between structured logging and un
structure logging and the best practices
for logging like centralized logging log
rotation and retention contextual and
meaningful logs and avoiding sensitive
data like passwords and API Keys then we
will look at monitoring different types
of monitoring like infrastructure
monitoring application performance
monitoring uptime monitoring the
different tools that are used in
monitoring like Prometheus grafana and
how to manage alerts and notifications
by defining thresholds creating alerts
and avoiding alert fatigue by only
creating action alerts and ensuring that
alerts are meaningful and necessary then
we'll take a look at observability the
three pillars of observability which are
logs metrics and traces the best
practices around it the security and
compliance of log management after that
we'll move on to graceful shutdown why
do we need graceful shutdown and how
does it work behind the scenes what are
the different use cases for example you
might need it when server restarts or or
scaling in Cloud environments or
microservices or long running jobs how
it works like signal handling sigor
signant and sill signals what are the
different steps of graceful shutdown for
example it starts with capturing a
signal and then it stops accepting
requests then it completes an inflight
requests and then it closes external
resources like database connections or
any open files Etc and at last it
terminates the app after that we'll move
on to security the different aspects of
security in a backend code base avoiding
different security attacks like SQL
injection no SQL injection xss csrf
broken authentication insecure
deserialization and principles of a
secure software design for example least
privilege defense in depth fail secure
defaults separation of Duties security
by Design then we'll look at the
importance of input validation and
sanitization and rate limits and content
security policy course and same side
cookie and the importance of monitoring
events after that we have scaling and
performance the different metrics of
performance like response time resource
utilization identifying bottlenecks
caching and database optimization for
example avoiding n plus1 query problems
and ensuring proper use of joints and
using lazy loading where appropriate
then we have using database indexes to
speed of read operations on frequent VAR
Fields like indexing foreign keys or
search Fields how to process data in
batches to minimize database load and
improve performance for large data sets
how to avoid memory leaks like closing
file handles database connections or
cleaning of after a long process
minimizing Network overhead by reducing
payload size and using compression we'll
look at how to do performance testing
and profiling we look at some of the
best practices for writing performant
code like focusing on writing clear and
maintainable code first without
premature optimization and writing
modular code to make it easier to
optimize individual components without
affecting the entire system ensuring
that if a particular resources under
load are unavailable the system degrades
gracefully without crashing and how to
offload non critical tasks like sending
emails or logging to background
processes or task use to free of
resources for more critical operations
then we have concurrency and parallelism
what are the difference between
concurrency and parallelism and how
concurrency helps in IO bound task and
how parallelism helps in CPU bound tasks
then we have object storage and large
files we'll look at some of the common
use cases when we use object storage
like awss 3 and how to manage large
files with chunking and streaming and
we'll look at multiart file uploads then
we have realtime backend systems where
we take a look at web sockets or servers
and events and pubs of architecture to
that we have testing and code quality
here we take a look at different types
of testing unit testing integration
testing end to end testing functional
testing regression testing performance
testing load and stress testing user
acceptance testing security testing
we'll take a look at what is test driven
development how to automate test in cicd
environments how to manage code quality
with external linting and formatting
tools and what are the measures of code
quality and coverage like quality
metrics like cyclomatic complexity which
measures complexity of a function by
counting the number of possible paths
through the code and we have
maintainability index which basically
quantifies how easy it is to maintain a
code based on the complexity lines of
code and other factors then we'll take a
look at a very interesting set of
principles which is called 12 Factor app
after that we'll move on to open API
standards what is the need of this
standards and why should we stick to it
what are the benefits of it what are the
use cases like documentation Automation
and the ecosystem surrounding it like
Swagger Corden postmen and what is the
history the Swagger to open API
transition and what are the different
versions that are currently active and
what are the key concepts of open API
documents for example there is API pass
the request and response definition
there is parameters there is schemas and
what is the structure of an OPN API
document there is metadata there is
paths there is components there is
security definitions and there is
responses we'll see what are the new
features of open API 3.0 and 3.1 what
are the tools surrounding open API for
example Swagger UI Cen Postman what are
the best practices like avoiding
duplication and sticking to standards
we'll look at a very interesting
development method which is API First
Development where you define your open
API standard or write your open API spec
first and then you start creating the
apis after that we'll move on to web
hooks what are the use cases of web
hooks by like sending notification third
party Integrations what are the
differences between API versus web hook
for the same use case for example for
API we might have to use polling which
is client side initiated compared to web
hooks which is pushing is server
initiated what are the key components of
web hooks for example the web hook URL
event triggers payload HTTP method the
response handling what are the best
practices surrounding web hooks like web
hook signature verification like using
http PS and quick response retry logic
logging how to test web hooks with enro
real world use cases like STP Payment
Processing GitHub web hook slack Discord
TWU Etc and at last we'll take a look at
what are some devops Concepts and
backend engineer should be familiar with
for example some of the Core Concepts
like continuous integration continuous
delivery continuous deployment the
devops practices like infrastructure is
code config management Version Control
the different tools surrounding devops
for example creating containers with
Docker or orchestrating container with
kubernetes and cicd pipelines and how to
scale your service horizontal scaling
versus vertical scaling and different
deployment strategies like red green
deployment rolling deployment Etc and
that's about it this is all the concepts
that we are going to cover in the next
30 or 40 videos so stay tuned